quand il y aurait violation des
obligations de confinement la première
sanction serait celle d'une
contravention de 4e classe donc puni
d'une amende forfaitisés de 135 euros
si cette amende n'est pas honorée à ce
moment là elle ça pourra monter jusqu'à
375 euros
si dans les quinze jours il y à une
nouvelle infraction à cette obligation
de confinement alors on passerait à une
amende de 5ème classe une contravention
de 5e classe soit 1500 euros et si dans
les 30 jours
on constate quatre violations 1 et moi
de vous interrompre mais cet amendement
que vous évoquez que vous défendez at il
été déposé ah oui vous l'avez oui tout
le monde sauf moi je suis confuse ne
tient pas donc je vous redonne la parole
je peux vous passer mon smartphone
monsieur le président si vous le
souhaitez donc je vous disais une amende
de 4e classe puis une contravention de
5e classe puis si dans les 30 jours
il y a eu quatre violation de cette
obligation de confinement alors on passe
à un délit c'est un délit qui serait
puni de trois mille 3700 euros d'amendé
et six mois de prison au maximum
pourquoi est-ce que je ne suis pas en
dessous de 6 mois de prison c'est tout
simplement parce que pour pouvoir juger
en comparution immédiate c'est-à-dire
pendant le temps de la durée du
confinement
je suis obligé d'avoir un quantum de six
mois de prison et donc il me semble plus
éventuellement un travail d'intérêt
général ou bien une peine de suspension
permis le juge évidemment choisissant
dans ses différents dans ses différents
étiage ce qui lui semblent les
meilleures sanctions et les meilleures
réponses possibles donc je ce que je
vous propose
au vu de vos propres réflexions c'est un
amendement qui est très graduée pour
sanctionner cette obligation de
confinement